our next question is from Dallas yeah my
name is Dallas I'm currently living in
Kate Main New Jersey and I'm new to
minimalism um so I'm only in like the
first hundred of your podcast so I don't
know if you've touched on this but I was
wondering Ryan said in one of the
episodes um during his packing party
that the first things that he got back
out of the boxes were his pacifiers and
I was wondering if you guys could
elaborate on that and say how you got
rid of the pacifiers thanks so much
absolutely fact you know what because
Ryan and I did the packing party
together I saved those initial pacifiers
that he unpacked Alabama can you unveil
the pacifiers no I literally had a box
of pacifiers and uh yeah my favorite
one's the dark blue
one I like the beige one myself have
never seen these before in my life oh
that is good here
go
what we're trying something new on the
podcast
if you just listen to the audio version
uh we have a bowl of pacifiers here now
obviously that is not what Dallas is
asking but Ryan I thought this was
interesting because when you did your
packing party which is highlighted in
our last Netflix film if you went the
best representation of that less is now
just go to netflix.com thee minimalist
you can watch that there but what
happened is you box up everything as if
you were moving and your initial
inclination was to begin to start
unpacking some pacifiers what you called
pacifiers and these were sort of things
that actually got in the way can you
talk about some of those things that you
those pacifiers after you unpack these
actual pacifiers what else did you
unpack well yeah I mean it's a it's just
a great metaphor and that's why it's so
used all the time it is something that
is soothing a uncomfortable feeling so
as a pacifier with a baby they have uh
you know this this uncomfortable feeling
you put a paci in their mouth and ah
life is good well my pacifier was uh
Coors Light it was DVD players oh my God
I'm so old it was uh it was up my TV um
my uh you know Xbox and anything else
that I was using to try and um just
forget the day so I'd come home from
work and it was like okay how can I drop
everything as soon as possible and um
meditation didn't come to mine I just uh
you know how can I pacify myself exactly
so meditation is hard that's not a
pacifier really right yeah yeah so no I
mean it's it is that's exactly what I
was talking about just all those things
that I use to distract myself from the
discomfort that I felt coming home from
work wait hold up so I'm just digging
into this for the first time so you
literally put a pacifier in your mouth
during those moments when you thought
about these things or is this is it a
symbol to represent that you want a this
pacifier is a metaphor I've never owned
a pacifier in my adult life okay okay
well listen listen because you know some
people use the swearing J right there
are things you can do that that feel
embarrassing or unpleasant as a way way
to remind yourself of just how goofy
this would be to do this so I thought
what you literally did was you put a
pacifier in your mouth to make yourself
realize what it looks like spiritually
for you to medicate on those things I I
think we should advance that as a
strategy love thought dude that's a
great thought yeah I mean I think you
were doing that metaphorically by saying
by calling these things pacifiers and
and that's the thing when we talk about
cuz these things are your security
blanket in a way right but it's never
the security blanket that keeps the
child secure they might feel like it is
I know Ella for the longest time had
this little it was a security blanket it
was just tattered it was in three
different pieces she would tie it
together I mean it was like a napkin at
this point but she was holding on to it
right because she felt a sense of
security with but of course that never
kept her secure the same way that these
items didn't actually soothe you in the
way that is fulfilling or uh life
affirming lifegiving in fact they got in
the way of living a meaningful life yeah
yeah man it's so easy to just have those
things I mean dude we're all waking up
and we're like okay how can I just not
feel bad today like I mean I I can't
tell you the morning I didn't wake up
like that and um yeah so we reach for
the the thing that is simplest to reach
for and the thing that we've conditioned
ourselves to use so there's no judgment
against the pacifier or a security
blanket or six-pack of corite um it's
just uh you know there might be um there
might be ways to pacify yourself or
eliminate um the emotions and the things
that you have going on that make you
need the pacifier I think it's okay to
judge it for yourself especially right
like hey this cor is light it's my
judgment this isn't actually helping me
it's hurting me or this uh I brought out
the the Internet modem and at home I
realize I'm pacifying myself with social
media with Facebook or Instagram or
whatever DK maybe we could talk about
some of those pacifiers in our lives
that we go to whenever we feel that
sense of discomfort I know for a lot of
us as soon as we get out of bed or maybe
we're still in bed there's the phone
start scrolling scrolling becomes a
pacifier I often say that scrolling is
the new smoking smoking is another
pacifier almost literally at that point
I mean what you're doing is harming
yourself in order to get that momentary
burst of of uh stimulation that you get
from a cigarette or for other people it
can be alcohol for someone else it could
be television for someone else it's 45
minutes of Tik Tok videos what are some
of these PA pacifiers that you've
identified when talking to people all
over the country I don't know why he's
attacking me like
this hey I can just go within and say
hey what have been your your pacifiers
and I can think of fast
food uh I can think of talking social
activity and if you're listening to any
of these things asking yourself well
what's wrong with those things nothing
it's not that pacifiers are wrong
pacifiers have a place they're not wrong
they're not evil it's just a pacifier is
something that you use to eliminate pain
rather than Express passion so it's why
you do it you can take something that's
perfectly innocent and if it's an
expression of creativity and Joy then
that's not a pacifier that's passion
right but if you're relying on it to
eliminate pain to distract you from the
work that you have to do to get well
then it becomes a pacifier and so
anything that makes you comfortable and
makes the questions go away the
questions that you need to answer in
order to know who you are and how you
want to show up in the world that
becomes your pacifier so for me it's all
of those things and I think what happens
is sometimes we find something that
appears virtuous to the rest of society
Y and now this is my good pacifier oh
the even alcohol is better than heroin
right sure because it's
social oh my
stars but it's socially acceptable to go
out to a bar with friends but that can
be pacification or going out with
friends can be a really rewarding
experience I love one of the things that
Ryan did as he started reshaping some of
his relationships we wrote about this in
our last book love people use things
what happened was you said hey I'll
still hang out with you we're not going
to go to that bar anymore and a lot of
those people they cease to exist in your
life now yeah it was it was uh
incompatibility and like that's okay I
didn't judge them for it they didn't
judge me for it it was just okay we're
not doing the same things anymore but
yeah if you want to avoid um the
pacifiers that are harmful then you got
to stop hanging out with people who are
only going to hang out with you in those
situations using those pacifiers venting
complaining is one of those sneaky
pacifiers because it's not inherently
wrong and there is a context where
complaining is a healthy thing and it's
cathartic cathartic for you but it also
has kind of like this unquestioned
status where surely if you're just
blowing off some steam and talking about
your bad day you're getting better right
but it's possible to get caught up in a
cycle of complaining where you are using
the the verbal expression of blame the
verbal expression of resentment as a way
to hide from your life and what you need
to do to get well
and the question is what are you hiding
from like that is if if people are
having a hard time with pacifiers the
question is like what are you hiding
from and for me I mean I was I used to
hide from so many things and what I've
realized like in the last I don't know 3
six months you know what I hide from
most often what's that being quiet with
myself and it's like I'm just now
starting to learn how to enjoy that
quiet time with myself cuz even when we
moved to Missoula and I started doing
these experiments to like to be with
like on my own like I saw Josh going to
movies by himself and out to dinner by
himself and I'm like what a
psychopath and then I'm like wait that's
actually sounds like a pretty healthy
thing like to go out and be with
yourself so when I was with myself I
would still be in these um stimulating
environments so now I find myself like
when I get quiet is when I start to
reach for different pafi as I start to
scroll or whatever it is and uh yeah
it's I was telling Mariah the other day
I'm like I realizing I hate it when I
don't have anything to say I don't know
why that is man but it drives me crazy
when I don't have anything to say I did
an added value a few weeks ago on the
podcast for the show Messiah have you
seen it yet no came out in 2020 and for
some reason I missed it I watched it
recently and it's about this Messianic
figure it's like is he Jesus is he uh a
new Messiah whatever is he a fraud like
we don't know as the show unfolds and
then maybe we do know by the end but uh
throughout that you never see him react
he's so calm and he Revels in the
silence but he's also okay with talking
as well when it is required when it adds
more value than silence he will talk but
otherwise the silence is the place that
he you see him and he's like utterly
comfortable and that is a place that I
aspire to be and I certainly am not
there a lot of the time but it's the one
of my favorite quotes from Pascal is all
of man's problems stem from his
inability to sit alone quietly in an
empty room yes and that's when we bring
out the pacifiers because I can't sit
alone quietly in an empty room I hope
you enjoyed that highlight from the
minimalist private podcast if you'd like
another highlight check out this video
if you'd like to watch the minimal
episode check out this video or if you'd
like to dive deep into full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast head over
to patreon the link is in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube channel 100%
advertisement free